Adrien is in Florida hi Adrian welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave what's
are you good man how can I help
good hey so my question is I'm looking
to buy a used car I'm a very big car guy
so it happens to be a Corvette zo6 40
years old cool it'll be coming out
around 55,000 I think it was um I'm
currently 23 I own two businesses a
commercial property management business
which I manage about 50 million in
commercial real estate and a design
agency based out of Bangladesh between
both I make around 200 and sank a year
I've managed to save about 250 K cash
which I have now and I save every month
around ten thousand and you're out of
there you have a lease yeah I know that
okay good you have a car felishj you
shoulda never went to college
yeah I have a leased car I currently pay
about 750 a month for that and this
would be my first time actually buying
financing I'm just not sure this is the
right oh I do plan on getting in why
would you financial you have 250
thousand in cash why don't you just
write a check for it because I know I'm
gonna be able to use that money much
more wise come on goodbye some real
estate and get much more return from
that than $15,000 yeah now you're
kidding yourself
okay listen have we happen yeah Dorian
your funds go ahead we have one so in my
family were split into two ways my older
brother's residential rent in the
residential industry and then my uncle
is in commercial and the residential
side is much easier to put fifty
thousand and get you know seven eight
percent cap return on houses especially
duplexes and triplexes
and that'll probably be the first move
I'll do but if not I'll just invest in a
sort of commercial first date
well you're obviously a stud I mean 23
years old you're making unbelievable
money you're like a freak you're awesome
I'm so impressed
the I did the same thing when I was your
age
made two and $50,000 a year but it was
in 1982 dollars not 19 not 20 $20 so
it's more like 500k I guess today but
and I was buying and selling real estate
and I was managing real estate that I
owned I was highly leveraged and I went
broke because of the leverage the bank
got sold to another Bank looked over and
said I don't like your plan anymore
I wasn't even late they called our notes
we had a lot of commercial paper which
means they can just yell out quality
collateral and just call your notes and
ruin your freakin life and I was so
stupid I didn't know that so by the time
I was 28 I was bankrupt by the time I
was 25 I was a millionaire making
$250,000 a year so been there done that
I think you're probably smarter than me
just talking to you are in terms of
intellect what you're pulling off
there's very impressive but the the
thing about leverage is it it'll bite
you in the butt it'll come back and get
you it's a two-edged sword and everybody
thinks that they're not the one that you
you know I've got this leverage monster
under control and so I don't buy real
estate unless I pay cash for it I don't
buy anything unless I pay cash for it
and I own several hundred million
dollars in real estate and I pay cash
for a hundred percent of it the building
we're sitting in is worth 70 million
then I built it with cash so but it
takes me more time than it's taken you
because you've done this very very
quickly and at a very young age so if
you're going to pursue a life of debt
then you really don't need my answer I
don't mean that in a snarky way but
you're just running on a completely
different value system and a completely
different set of principles that I have
used to build my life after I went broke
doing it the way you're doing it so all
of that said I would be debt-free and I
wouldn't be looking at a cap rate on a
house unless it was a cash-on-cash cap
rate or an internal rate of return that
had cash-on-cash built into the rate of
return which is how I look at my real
estate so I look at cash on cash return
and then I look at the internal rate of
return on the current value of the
property which includes the appreciation
the depreciation and the cash flows so
all of that's built in there
gather in the formulas and you know
those formulas apparently just listening
to you all that to say dude if you're
gonna buy a big fancy car for God's
sakes pay cash for it at least do that
you've got $200,000 in the bank
you would not borrow on your Corvette to
buy a house and effectively that's what
you're doing so don't do it by the way
the new Corvettes are amazing I got one
of them's absolutely incredible so help
me with this I need you to counsel me
Dave should a 23 year old have a $55,000
car yeah yeah yeah if you're making
$50,000 a year okay and he's got Turner
and he's got $50,000 cash in the bank
yep and he's other than oh whatever real
estate crap he's doing he's debt-free he
doesn't have a bunch of student loan
debt he doesn't have a least he didn't
tell us if he did right but yeah it's
not about age it's got ratios a 33 43 53
year old it's all ballad but ratios who
should ever have a $400,000 car yeah it
goes against the the the ratio I get
that yeah I mean but I mean who should
my buddy who makes fifteen million right
and is in his thirties you know and is
worth about forty million dollars you've
got different friends than me you know
but I mean I don't have many of those
friends but I mean an impressive young
dude half my age about but he's bought a
four thousand our car and my Antioch
Tennessee goes what the crap who needs a
four hundred thousand dollar car you
know what that is hmm that's just
redneck talking who needs any time you
have that come out of your mouth who
needs a dot dot dot means you have
figured out how to run someone else's
life that's me being jealous is with
that exactly Australians call it tall
poppy syndrome okay once the one poppy
gets taller than all the others it must
be cut down uh okay yeah so you have to
look over there it's your friend who
goes and you don't know what their
numbers are but you have to make a
judgment call and call that an immoral
act hmm see who needs this is a
statement of morality mm-hmm it's an
immoral act for for a 23 year old to buy
a 55 thousand our car it's not not at
all now in fact that can afford it as
long as you pays cash for it I'd have no
problem with it but he's got other
issues going on behind the scenes that
I'd already address but that's the thing
is look at ratios you know they came out
against
besos
he bought the most expensive home I
think it was in the United States has
ever been done I believe it was it was
certainly in California and it was a
some number of whatever in la Los
Angeles some ridiculous number and it
was in Beverly Hills and but when you
run the numbers back as a percentage of
his income or percentage of his net
worth and it was like a hundred like a
guy making a hundred thousand dollars a
year about a five thousand our house
right I mean it was nothing and so it's
all about when you look at ratios in
other words it he could think about one
of those a week and burn it down mm-hmm
and it doesn't bother isn't that worth
it doesn't bother his future and that's
what you're looking at is are you out of
line in other words if you're
consumption of something is such a big
percentage of your life that's an
indication you're looking for stuff to
make you happy mmm and maybe that's
where I was approaching it from is
what's a 23 year old trying to fill up
with a $55,000 car but that brings me
back to this what is anybody that's
right well it goes back to that
fundamental attribution error where I'm
deciding I'm gonna put myself in your
head and decide why you just did what
you just did
yeah and I got no business doing that
why do I need a raptor you know they
cost more than 55 grand well that's kind
of a cool like when I park my I won't
use Tundra next to it it's a cool tree
but it's okay but I mean there's no
difference I mean I don't need that am I
trying to fulfill something to make me
feel like a real man or something cuz I
got a big butt truck you know I mean is
that is that really what's come on no I
just like the dadgum truck that's
exactly right there you know so but you
know there's attribution mm-hmm that
somebody says okay well I don't like
your jokes about Prius Ramsey so I'm mad
at your Raptor now and you know I mean
that kind of stab solutely and it's I
need to go to the mirror first that's
what you're saying it's it's it's a
harsh I don't like looking in the mirror
that mirror is dadgum rip you up man it
because it's I wrote a lot about this
stuff in the legacy journey hmm because
we started dealing with this whole thing
of you know well that's not a holy car
and we're like yeah we figured out you
know apparently a used Honda because
Jesus said they're all in one Accord
right I mean you know it's just that's
the only car that's holy right a very
used old Honda but 1993 Camry past that
you're probably have lost your salvation
there you go because there's a starving
child somewhere on the planet and it's
your fault you know that's that
moralities
toxic bull well and twisted Marie can be
as proud of the things you don't have as
people of the things they are right I
think it's nonsensical there you go
that's well done look in the mirror
people ouch
myself included good grief